créée par un ancien fonctionnaire de
police du raid prox raid aventure
sillonnent le territoire français avec
un seul but rapprocher les jeunes la
population et la police
pour cela une dizaine de stands
permettaient de tester plusieurs
activités au palais des sports de
plaisir
bon
c'est bien parce qu'on apprend à ce
défaut si on se fait agresser dans la
rue il ya quand même des jeunes qui
pensaient qu'on n'était pas des vrais
policiers et le fait qu'on ait fait du
sol avec eux
son diary on a joué avec la police prend
ça a créé des liens parce que du coup
ils sont contents self-défense laser
game box secourisme encore techniques
d'interpellation en proposant ses
activités ludiques les policiers venus
bénévolement sur leur temps libre espère
changer leur image auprès du public
on a toujours un peu des questions drôle
par rapport à l' usage de l'armement
on leur explique la réalité du terrain
en fait on est là pour casser un peu les
stéréotypes ce qu'ils peuvent voir dans
les différentes séries policières soit
américaine ou même parfois française
aujourd'hui les jeunes qui respectait
plus la police et au contraire ça pour
nous le lien on va dire on les voit plus
comme les méchants avec son accord pour
arrêter ils sont comme nous quoi chaque
année ce dispositif s'arrête dans près
de 70 villes notamment celles où se
trouvent des quartiers considérés comme
sensibles
c'est une bonne idée avec les tout ce
qui s'est passé c'est un étang là avec
les attaques duvalier bout ça
sensibilise un peu le public
c'est la première fois que provoque ce
raid aventure faisait étape à plaisir
une opération qui a vocation à se
renouveler